شرطه الاحت اتحمت
المنزلون مننا
الخروج قوات كبيره من شرطه الاحتلال تحيط
بالمنزل وكما شاهدتم يقتحمون تماما كما
يحد
هي التي اقتحمت الميدان في تغطيه تعقيدات
المشهد في منطقه تصنف دول عده فيها ضمن
الاخطر على الصحفيين ومن بين ضحايا
الصحافه وشهدائها خلال العقدين الماضيين
عشرات الصحفيات فضلا عن تعرضهن لانتهاكات
اتصاب ومع هذا فان رفيقات المهنه صامدات
باسقات كالنخل في حقل الاعلام كونك اخترت
ان تكوني صحفيه فانت تلقائيا تنازلت عن
كثير من هدوئك الشخصي ومن حياتك
[موسيقى]
الشخصيه
لقد راينا ليس فقط في الشرق الاوسط ولكن
في كل العالم تهديدات رهيبه للصحفيات
بالقتل والاغتصاب اضافه الى المضايقات
التي تصله عبر المنصات الرقميه وقد راينا
ان الصحفيين الذكور قد يتعرضون للاساءه
ايضا الا ان الحال يبدو اسوا بكثير
بالنسبه الى الصحفيات للاسف التغطيه
مستمره دائما وفي فلسطين اكثر واكثر لم
تعطون حتى فرصه ربما ان يحزن
ان يتوقف مع كثير من الي التي تحدث في
فلسطين واسال هنا نجوان كيف يؤثر ذلك على
نفسيه الصحفيات العاملات في في فلسطين
بدات اكثر افكر بان من يقف امامي سيستهل
باي لحظه ان يطلق الرصاص علي هذا حدث بعد
اغتيال شيرين بدات افكر بعد اغتيال
شيرين ما هي الجدول من العمل الصحفي اذا
كنا لا نستطيع ان نحقق
عدالتها اذا كان الجاني لن يتعاقب جيفارا
ماذا لو اخبرتنا عن يعني نوع الظلم والضيم
الذي يقع عليكن كمراسل اثناء تغطيتك والذي
ربما لا تتمكن الكاميرات في كثير من
الاحيان من نقله طبع هو محاوله الثبات
و استمداد القوه بعدم اظهار اي نوع من
الخوف او الضعف هذا بيكون التحدي الاول في
العمل في الميدان في اوضاع صعبه يعني نحن
اعداء فقط نحن عدو جديد والان يمكن عدو
اكبر للاحتلال الاسرائيلي والمستوطنين في
نقل الحقيقه لا يريدون نقل الصوره لا
يريدون نقل
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه
ن